hallo ihr lieben ihr seht schon ich bin
nicht in meiner küche heute beginnt
wirklich neuer meilenstein für mich wir
haben uns vor zwei jahren in den kopf
gesetzt wir wollen den haselnuss markt
revolutionieren vor eineinhalb jahren
habe ich euch erzählt was das große
projekt ist meine eigene haselnuss creme
und mittlerweile auch viele verschiedene
varianten die haselnuss creme hat den
größten hype elfer bekommen und das
total berechtigt wie ich finde und jetzt
kommt nämlich der nächste großes der wir
werben ich kann es ja verraten am viel
ab dem 14 oktober in allen kaufland
filialen in ganz deutschland vertreten
nur solange der vorrat reicht es ist
nicht mal eben so sondern das war ein
harter weg bis dahin wir haben zusammen
mit kreativen köpfen unter den tisch
gesetzt und das erste was wir gemacht
haben ein display überhaupt erstmal zu
designen und ich zeige schon mal das
ergebnis das ist geworden dass da
wirklich verdammt viel arbeit und es
wird hier in deutschland gedruckt hier
per hand gefüllt ihr rad gesehen wird
alles per hand auf die displays gefüllt
und die werden nächste woche
ausgeliefert sind ab dem 14 oktober dann
einfach in den koffer markt stürmen
nimmt alles auseinander was könnt euch
die krise ganz ehrlich leute wenn ihr
wollt könnt ihr das ganze system
mitnehmen wenn ihr alle gläser auf dem
trade hofft nimmt euch doch das ganze
display könnte mitnehmen
[Musik]
ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt einen
kleinen rückblick wie überhaupt alles
zustande gekommen ist weil ich finde das
video schon genau erkennt das video aus
otto das war für mich die schönste reise
meines bisherigen lebens aber so ein
paar einblicke nochmal davon und dann
würde ich sagen sobald es bei kaufen ist
hamm sowie zwischen direkt rüber zu den
filialen und sind dann auch selber vor
ort oder
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob mein herz in köniz
mikrofon ist direkt darüber aber wir
stehen blatt vor kaufen ist das
allererste mal unser haselnuss krebs
direkt im kaufland kommt wir gehen
einfach mal direkt mit rein gucken und
an wo sie stehen einfach
auf der titelseite wird krank
veränderung und berna
fragen jetzt mal die mitarbeiterin was
ist grün sind hallo
die queen haben wir ganz hinten davor
nach offenburg gekommen ist gleich
direkt davor war super ich danke dir
ich komme gerade nicht klar ich bin am
zittern ich bin richtig und wittern hier
steht einfach dieses display woran wir
so lange gearbeitet haben diese grafik
allein schon dieses ich habe mir so
viele gedanken gemacht und dank an den
grafikern der findet er alle super
umgesetzt arten entstehen die einfach
hier recht irgendwo ich habe richtig
gänsehaut oder aber ich bin ich bin
sprachlos krankenhaus bringen spiel
richtig ich bin richtig stolz auf dich
haben sein
gesicht
ist auf jeden fall jetzt steht es hier
aber nur für kurze zeit wie gesagt das
ist gerade ausgepackt worden und ja
denke es wird nicht lange stehen
geschaffen
[Musik]
wir haben uns nochmal richtig coole
verlosung überlegt ihr könnt fünfmal
einen jahresvorrat wie scream gewinn
winkt ihr seid doch ein ganzes jahr
versorgt was ihr dafür tun es geht zu
eurer liebsten kaufland filiale und dann
macht ein foto entweder von aufsteller
oder von der creme in der postfiliale
ihr könnt auch kreativ sein entweder es
ist ein foto mit euch ohne äußeren video
und dann postet es entweder auf
instagram tik tok oder facebook und
schon landet ihrem los topf von aus groß
wird am 31 oktober
[Musik]